so you write in this part of the book
about evil
uh
quote
what is it that drives
evil
many things without doubt but one of
them is identified by several of the
great philosophers
is resentment
that sentiment is one of the greatest
drivers for people who want to destroy
colon blaming someone else for having
something you believe you deserve more
and you're saying this kind of
resentment
we don't know
as it surfaces whether it's genuine or
if it's uh used to sort of play games of
power to evil ends
um can you speak to this
to this this because it's just a
fascinating idea
that
one of the biggest drivers of evil in
the world
is resentment because if you look at
boy if you look at human history if you
look at hitler
uh so much of the propaganda so much of
the narrative was about resentment
does that surface or is it level or is
that deep there is that computer it can
be any of the above
let's first of all preface it everybody
has resentment
i mean i just i use it resonating which
is thought very similar to resentment
let's stick with resentment
so we don't sound too pretentious
um
the
let me give you a quick example of
somebody in our own day who has who has
a form of resentment vladimir putin
did you see navalny's documentary
putin's palace
yes yeah
you remember the stuff about uh putin as
a young kgb officer in germany
from the stuff about putin his first
wife's resentment of one of his kgb
colleagues who had
an apartment that was a few meters
bigger than the putin's apartment
yeah it's very interesting and by the
way i'm not saying that
you know vladimir putin became the man
he has become and invaded ukraine
because he didn't have an apartment he
liked him but in berlin or munich
wherever he was it's this distinct
possibility my point is
my point is is that
is that resentment is is a factor in all
human lives and we all feel it in
in our lives and it's
it's something it has to be struggled
against
resentment is in political terms can be
a deadly i mean it's an incredibly deep
thing to draw upon
and you mention hitler obviously one of
the things that hitler
played on was resentment obviously
uh
almost every revolution he does
i mean the french revolutionaries did as
well and we're not without cause
there's a good reason to feel that
versailles was not listening to paris
in the 1780s
and feel resentment for um
mary antoinette in her palace within the
palace
ignoring the bread shortages
in paris
so resentment is is a very
it's a very understandable thing and
sometimes it's justifiable and it's also
deadly to the person as it is to the
society um it's an incredibly deep deep
sentiment
somebody else is um got something that
you should have
and the
the problem about it is it it's it has
the potential to be endless
um you can do it your whole life
and one of the ways i've
sort of sort of found myself explaining
this to people is to say
it's also important to recognize that
resentment is something that can cross
absolutely every boundary
so for instance
it crosses all racial boundaries
obviously and i go without saying
more interesting is it crosses all class
boundaries and socioeconomic boundaries
and if i was to sort of simplify this
thought i would say
i guess that you and i and everybody
watching
knows or has known somebody in their
lives
who has
almost nothing in worldly terms
and is a generous person a kindly person
a giving person
a happy person even a cheerful person
and
i think we probably have also or many of
us would have met people who seem to
have everything
and who are filled with resentment
filled with resentment somebody else has
held them back from something their
sister once did something they said she
shouldn't she got this i should have got
that
and and on and on and on
it's a human trait
and
what one of the things that suggests to
me is that we therefore have a choice in
our lives about this this is something
which we can do something about not
limitlessly
but for instance
i mean there are very good reasons that
some people in their lives might feel
resentment
let's say you're involved in a car crash
and a friend
fell asleep at the wheel and that's why
you are spending the rest of your life
in a wheelchair it's a pertinent example
of this in american politics at the
moment um
you would be justified in feeling
resentment
and at some point you have to make a
decision which is am i going to be that
person
or a different person
but even in that case you're saying at
the individual level and that societal
level is destructive to the mind even
when you're quote-unquote justified it
brought you it rots you because
the best you can do
is to eke out your days unfulfilled
so the antidote as you describe is
gratitude yes
gratitude is the antidote to
evil in a sense
so gratitude is the individual level
into societal level gratitude is
certainly the answer to resentment
i um
i quote in the war in the west this this
when i read it uh the first time a few
years ago i was absolutely flawed by um
the brothers
of uh
not everything in it by the way i won't
get into it but i have i have some very
big structural criticisms of the novel
no now you're just sweet talking to me
because i'm a does the esky fan but i
appreciate this
oh okay
well we could get into what i see as the
structural flaws in the brothers
carrying out anyway um now i'm i'm
offended and triggered yeah no i mean
this is
coming out of macbeth and saying i
didn't think it was much good yeah
there's structural flaws yeah i thought
the ending stank yeah middle wasn't very
good no um when i read that that novel i
was i was flawed by a couple of things
one is one is of course at the moment
where we realize the devil appears
the moment that ivan says to his brother
you know he visits me and you realize
that he's talking about the devil whole
novel goes into this
totally different space anybody is even
more than you've already realized the
novel's about
and then when the conversation occurs
between the van and the devil remember
dre i think he says he describes him as
dressed as a french friend redressed in
the french style
of the uh early part of the 19th century
very strange the devil will be dressed
like that but sort of
um
and and and if you remember that he and
he sort of crossed the legs and rather a
bane figure
but but the devil mentions impassing
to ivan that um
he says i don't know why
gratitude is not a
uh
an instinct that's been given to me
and um yeah you're not allowed this is
not
uh given the role of being the devil
this is not one of the things there's
not one of the things and you think and
of course only a genius of dostoevsky's
stature could i mean unless a genius
would have made a whole novel out of
that inside
uh only dostoevsky can just throw it
away because it's such an abundance of
riches that he still has to get through
the structural problems aside but the
the the uh the passive aggressive nate
the the microaggression in this
conversation that's palpable
little knife fight kind of no but but
the reason i mention is because of
course when i thought
this this is such a brilliant insight by
garcia because
why why would why would gratitude not be
a sentiment the devil was capable of the
answer is of course that
if the devil was capable of gratitude he
wouldn't be the devil
he'd be somebody else
he has to be incapable of gratitude
do you think for dostoevsky that was as
strong as an insight as as it is for you
because i think that's a really powerful
idea that with gratitude
you you don't get the resentment that
rots you from the core
yes i think it was one of the just
endless things that he saw in us
and
and the way i put it is that i mean i
also think of it and think in terms of
the the era of deconstruction which is
one of the things i'd like us to call
the era that's now ending
the era of deconstruction
was the era that started let's say from
the 60s onwards
and was
originally an academic game that then
spilled out into the wider culture which
was
let's take everything apart let's pull
it all apart
um there are lots of problems with it
one is it's quite boring
you don't get an awful lot from it
uh
you also have the problem of what
children find when they try to do this
with bicycles which is they can take it
apart quite easily but they can't put it
back together
um
and the era of of
taking things apart as a game
is one we've lived through and it's been
highly destructive
but you can do it for quite a long time
i'm going to look at this society and
i'm going to take it apart by showing
systemic problems i'm going to
at the end of that what have you got
what have you done what have you
achieved
we need to interrogate this okay
interrogate by all means ask questions
but interrogate there's a deliberate
hostility to this
i'm going to interrogate this thing and
take it apart and again at the end of it
what have you got
whether you're interrogating a text
or a piece of music
or an idea or a society fine
question endlessly question yes
interrogate
assumes it's all um
a criminal in a cell
and it's guilty
and therefore it must be taken apart
and that's what we've been doing for
decades in the west
and
that's resentment that's one by-product
of resentment
you can't build the thing but you know
how to take it apart
is a little bit of resentment
good so you have
you know that i love tom waits and he
has a song where a little drop of i like
my town with a little drop of poison
is it good to do that
is it good to have a little bit of
poison in your drink
depends what poison is and it depends if
you know not to have another drink
it might be the case you find out some
alcoholics do that one was
too many and ten is not enough
so there's a natural
in this case
this kind of deconstruction as a
slippery slope it becomes an addiction
it becomes a drug and you just can't
stop well you have you'd have to wean
yourself off it and try to start
creating again
okay you'd have to start trying to put
things together again
um
[Music]
something
i think might be in the throes of
starting as it happens
you